[Music]
hi everybody my name is mark Mandal and
i'm a developer advocate for Google
cloud for games today I'm gonna talk to
you about scaling globally with game
servers and a gun is so today we're
gonna talk about dedicated game servers
for large-scale multiplayer games if
you're not familiar with dedicated game
servers very quickly what they are is a
full simulation of what's happening
inside a game usually running somewhere
in the cloud and what happens is is the
people who are playing a particular game
session will all connect to an
individual dedicated game server process
usually they'll send things like hey I'm
moving forward or maybe I did an action
like fired a rocket and it's up to that
dedicated game server to basically be
the authority of what's happening inside
that game and send that information back
to the players so that they know exactly
what's happening inside the game this is
really important for large-scale
multiplayer games because it enables
people to have a lot of control over the
latency experience that people have with
these real-time games this is important
because you have geographic control over
exactly where your dedicated game
servers exist because players around the
world are gonna play your game so if you
have very low latency requirements which
many real-time multiplayer games do you
can put it in a particular place around
the world so that you can have control
and have knowledge over exactly how fast
the information is going backwards and
forwards from these dedicated game
servers so that sounds simple in
practice right but orchestrating these
thousands of machines and potentially
thousands of dedicated game server
processes around the world is
essentially a tricky problem there's a
lot of moving parts that you need to
look at and a lot of things that could
potentially go wrong so that's really
what I want to talk to you about today
how are we solving that problem with
Google cloud game servers and they're
going as project so let's start from the
foundation some things you've probably
already heard of so many of you are
probably already familiar with the
kubernetes project if you're not it's an
open source project initially started by
Google that's built for running
processes or software processes over a
large number of machines inside
cluster cribben Eddie's is fantastic you
can come to Google cloud run it on our
gke platform you can also run it
wherever you want to run it as well this
is super useful for game servers because
it means then that you can put your game
servers in places that your players are
and players show up in all sorts of
interesting places around the world
so kubernetes is a great foundation for
if you want to run game servers so a
ganas is another wonderful project you
may necessarily have heard of it's an
open source project that extends
kubernetes so that kubernetes
understands how dedicated game servers
work and what a dedicated game server
life cycle is and how its managed it's
also great that it's open source much
like kubernetes because this again means
that a ganas can be run wherever your
player bases are potentially inside your
own studio or your on-site journal on on
your own laptop as well it's a great
project that's been running for several
years now and we went 1.0 back in
september it has a variety of
functionality that is super useful
specifically for running dedicated game
server workloads including native
integration with kubernetes tooling auto
scaling capabilities sdk integrations
with things like unreal and unity a
bunch of cost optimization functionality
as well as metrics and dashboards so you
can see exactly what's happening inside
the fleet's of game servers that you're
running inside of OCONUS but we were
talking previously we were talking about
how we want to run this in a global
network of distributed game servers that
run around the world and that's where
things do get hot again algún is is a
fantastic project but it really works
primarily with in a singular kubernetes
cluster so if I want to cluster machines
and say what region or a zone inside say
Google cloud this is fantastic but if I
want to run these in multiple regions
around the world please get a bit more
complicated and this is where we step
into Google cloud game servers Google
cloud game servers in a managed is a
management layer that sits on top of
open source of ganas it provides a
wonderful set of functionality and
features that makes it easy to
orchestrate and scale multiple clusters
of organiz around the world while still
not locking you into a specific vendor
package and also giving you a lot of
ability and power to be able to run your
game server is it exactly the way that
you want to so how does this look
and what does we need to do to get
started so we're gonna get stuck into
that so at a high level what concepts do
we have so you're probably already
familiar with the Google cloud project
nothing there has changed our best
practice here is saying that you
probably want a singular project for a
singular game title and environment so
if I have a game X and I have it in
production that is generally a project
next we have game server clusters these
are simply a gun as clusters that have
registered themselves with Google cloud
game servers so that Google cloud game
servers is aware of them you have full
access still to that gke or kubernetes
cluster so you can do extra stuff in
there if you want up to you if you
choose to but it's simply just that
kubernetes cluster that is registered
but we also need a way to organize those
clusters together for example I might
want to have a set of clusters that are
in US central to help support my u.s.
player base I might just say okay cool
I want to group those together so that
they're essentially the same from a
latency perspective or an organizational
perspective so that all the players I
know could choose any one of those
clusters that are sitting in US central
we've called that concept realms that is
simply a user-defined grouping of
clusters such that we know that the
latency requirements for those clusters
are going to be basically the same for
any players that are connecting to from
there
we have game server configs and
deployments that's how we can set up our
fleets and auto scaling capabilities and
then deploy them out either globally or
even just to particular sections of our
global fleet of game servers it gives us
a lot of control and I'm going to dig
into that a little bit more so just
looking at it in a different way here's
a really great example of this
particular game X we were just talking
about so here we have multiple realms we
have a u.s. realm we have a Europe realm
and we have a Japan realm and we also
have this working with multiple clusters
within each of the realm you can see in
the u.s. realm we have a GCP cluster we
have an on-prem cluster inside the
Europe realm we have a GCP cluster and
another cluster on another cloud and in
Japan we're just using GCP
because for there it makes sense what
we're then able to do is apply these
Google cloud deployments and configs
across all the realms so that we can
manage these global fleets of games
clusters and provide a wonderful
experience for all that players
regardless of where they are so how does
this work how do we get started
pretty straightforward first step start
with open source organize the migration
paths from agonist to Google Cloud Game
Servers is actually really easy so you
can definitely get started there if
that's the place you want to get started
the next step from that is you need to
register that cluster with the Google
Cloud game server system to do that you
need to turn on the game services API
which is a one-click process you then
need to define your realms within your
system how you want to organize each of
these clusters into location-based areas
then from there define your configs and
define your deployments how do you want
your fleets and order scaling
capabilities to be pushed out across all
these clusters that's really about it
it's a multiple step process but it's
relatively simple and if you're already
familiar with a gun is you're gonna find
it really familiar as well so let's get
stuck into an actual demo so I can show
you exactly how all this works so let's
actually run some game servers earlier
I've prepared for clusters that are set
up I have two in Europe and I have two
in the United States you can see these
here they're just playing old google
kubernetes engine clusters nothing
special about them except for the fact
I've already installed a gun eyes on
them and I've already coordinated them
with their realms so let me give you a
preview of what the dashboard looks like
for Google cloud game servers so here
you can see that I've set up two realms
I've set up one in Europe and I've set
up one in the United States and I've
registered each of these clusters
appropriately so you can see the two
here inside Europe and the two here
inside the United States that's really
all I had to do right now I don't have
any games whoever's running on them but
I'm ready to go everything is ready for
me to run some game servers so I'm gonna
come over here to my trusty cloud shell
that I already have set up and connected
to everything I've got it connected to
one of my clusters so if you're familiar
with a gun is I can do cube CT I'll get
game servers and right now I don't have
anything but as you can see here my
kuben
these cluster doesn't understand how
game servers work so we want to deploy
some game servers via a fleet which is a
big set of game servers to all the
clusters that I have inside my set so
I'm actually I open my editor we have
here what we call our fleet
configuration it's gonna be part of what
we call a config for Google cloud game
servers so if you used a goddess before
this probably looks really familiar
here we have our image for what we want
to actually run is our game server how
many of them we want to run so here I
have a replicas of two and we also have
a version which is right here we're just
gonna put a tag on it called version 1.0
put this label on it so we can see some
things we go forward so the first thing
I actually need to do is set up what we
call a deployment so I'm just gonna
close this editor right now so Google
Cloud Game Servers we're just gonna do a
deployment we're gonna create it and
we're just gonna call it SDK SDK because
the game we're actually going to be
using is a game called super tux Cup
it's a really fun multiplayer racing
game that some people may already be
familiar with because it's been around
for a while it's really cute and
adorable so a deployment is basically a
placeholder for where we want to put out
configurations we want to organize them
and then we can apply from there which
we'll see in a minute next we're going
to create our configuration so let's do
that
configs create we're gonna attach it to
our deployment which is SDK we're gonna
pass in our fleet config file which is
fleet - v1 GMO and we're gonna call it
v1 pretty simple stuff now this actually
isn't going to apply anything to our
cluster yet nothing's been created at
this stage so if we want to actually
apply it we're you need to actually do a
rollout action this gives us a lot of
steps in between and we're gonna look at
an extra one here that gives us a lot of
control and a lot of warning a lot of
preview on exactly what's gonna happen
inside our cluster because we're dealing
with a global scale system here and we
really don't want to mess this up so
let's do our rollout so we're going to
look at our deployments so we have this
this sdk deployments we want to apply a
defaults deployment sorry
date rollouts so we want you to roll it
out I'm gonna say our defaults config is
v1 and we want to do a dry run and we
want to do it to our SDK deployment so
what does this mean
so we're saying we wanted to a roll out
we want to push this out to all the
clusters that we have but we want to
drive run it first so we want to be able
to have a look at exactly where this is
going to go so we have a lot of feelings
of confidence and safety and what it is
that we're doing so here we can see we
are have a config v1 and we can see that
it's being applied to each of the
clusters that are around the globe all
four of them which is exactly well on so
we're like great that's awesome
that's exactly what we want so now let's
run that again with no dry run and we'll
see that's now going to start pushing it
out to all the clusters we have so that
fleet that we set up previously with
that v1 config of that fleet that's now
going to start rolling out to everywhere
we're gonna see two game servers so if
we actually have a look in this u.s.
cluster we can see that we have two game
servers there we can actually see that
it has v1 in the title there as well if
we want to have a quick look at it we
describe our game server we can see all
kinds of interesting information we
scroll up here we can see that version
label that 1.8 version and if we scroll
down we can also see that we have the
right the right image there as well so
that's looking pretty good now to prove
to you that it's running in multiple
clusters let's actually connect to our
us to cluster and do the same thing so
grab that information copy it connect
away we look at our game servers there
we can see we also have two game servers
there as well so you can see right like
we've been able to really easily set up
these fleets that run across multiple
clusters around the globe with only one
command and also do a preview of it as
well so we're gonna do an allocation
next part of both open source organize
and Google cloud game servers working
together is multi cluster allocation
system we actually have a gr PC endpoint
that gets used for this which is why I'm
using a script
to make that easier that is
authenticated with some certificates and
what this is doing is it's gonna hit one
of the endpoints on one of the clusters
the one that I'm actually connected to
you right now is us two it's gonna do an
allocation for those of you who aren't
familiar with organ is an allocation is
basically a special thing that says okay
give me a game server and then market is
allocated so that I know that there are
players playing on that particular game
server right and don't delete it we
don't want to delete game servers with
players are playing they tend to get mad
when that happens so we got back a game
server which is awesome let's actually
cube CT okay game servers we can look at
it this way which is super nice we can
see one of those is allocated I'm not
actually marked both of them as
allocated right now just for convenience
and we'll show you why in just a second
so let me grab that one we previously
allocated and we're actually gonna play
a game so this will be fun what I want I
want this here so pop over to super tux
cut in my command line and we'll click
run game let's pop that up so let's
connect to our allocated game server
that we just set up we'll connect there
excellent so that's connected I'm
connected I probably need some friends
to play with though so why don't we set
up some AI bots that will also have that
running so here we go here's here's a
script that I have running here that
will put three friends allow me to play
with some people run that wonderful now
we can see we have these three bots that
have joined me in this game and let's
start a race so I'm gonna play as puffy
I will choose that track that'll give me
a couple of seconds to crack down but
this is running directly against the
dedicated game server we have running on
one of our organized clusters that is
being managed by Google cloud game
servers at this stage so you can see
it's actually running against us central
and I'm able to play again so here I am
we're just waiting for the green light
to go ahead excellent driving and so I'm
playing this game against several
players who are also racing again
me all running from my local machine
it's a super cute game I love super
toxic odd we won't play for too long
it's fun okay that was cool alright I'm
gonna shut that down so you can see that
a games actually playing so coming back
to cloud show if we look at our game
servers we'll see now that we still have
one allocated one relly ready so super
toxic odd is great and that once we will
disconnect it it'll actually shut itself
down if you're not familiar with a gun
is it's going to make sure that we have
the right number of game servers ready
and available for us and we've said we
want to so throughs gonna be up but we
clearly have another player still
playing with that allocated game server
that's still sitting there as well we're
going to come back to a little bat to a
little bit later as well okay so we have
those two game servers but maybe we have
a new update maybe we have another game
server that also wants to come up in a
different way or with a bug fix or we
want to test out maybe a new level or
something like that
so we may not want to roll that out to
the entire globe all at the same time
maybe we want to do a test so in this
particular instance what we're gonna do
is we're just gonna roll that out to
Europe first see how that goes in that
player base and assuming everything goes
fine then we're also going to roll that
out to the rest of the world so we have
a v2 so if we come back to our editor
let's have a look here
excellent we have this v2 config so here
we've said okay we actually want to have
five replicas rather than two we're
gonna put a version to label on it
everything else for this demo we're
going to keep the same but you can
imagine you might have a whole new
version of this this game server that
you want to push up so to take this live
what we're gonna do is do exactly what
we did before configs
create we're also going to attach this
to our sdk deployment we're gonna have
our fleet config file of fleet v1 on
gamal and we're going to call this sorry
it's like feet to Tamil we're gonna call
this v2 so we'll create that so how then
do we do that sort of override sort of
situation where we just want it to run
in one particular cluster so we pop back
to our
we can write this thing called an
override Gemmell where you can see here
where we can write this thing called a
realm selector that says okay for these
particular realms I want to have this
particular configuration so here we're
gonna say okay we want the v2 config
let's actually apply this deployment but
with the override we had previously so
we are going to do a update roll out our
default config is still v1 but our
config override is override dot llamo we
still want to do a dry run we want to
see what's going to happen there and
we're applying it to our SDK deployment
there we go so this is actually kind of
interesting here so we can see here in
our US realm we would have that v1 setup
just the way it was before nothing
changed there but we can see here in our
EU clusters in our EU realm we have v2
and that's available
so let's actually roll that out do you
know dry run that's pushing out so we're
still connected to that u.s. cluster if
we want to have a look at what's
available there Game Servers we should
see that it's all the same yeah we still
have that allocated game server we can
still see we have v1 and that's
available so that's that's pretty cool
but if we pop back over to say an EU
cluster and let's connect to that okay
and we have a look at what game service
we have available here suddenly we can
see that we have both five game servers
not like the two we had previously and
we can see here that there the v2
instance which is super nice so we have
a lot of control here exactly how we
want these game server fleet instances
to be run around the world let's do one
more thing I just wanna do one more fun
thing which is let's push that v2
instance all around the world we can do
that very simply - what we've done
previously so we have a deployments we
do a update rollout we say our default
config is now v2 we are actually gonna
clear out config overrides and again
we'll do a dry run just to check to see
everything's okay and here we can see
okay we have that v2 instance running
across all the clusters that we own so
let's actually run that updating rollout
now I want to show you one more very
important thing we come back to that US
cluster we were connected to previously
remember that one we had allocated that
we use the multi cluster allocation to
get set up and ready to go we can have a
look here and well if we do cube CT okay
game servers that allocated game server
from previously that's still there this
is very similar exactly to what our
Gunners would do previously those
allocated game servers are essentially
very important we don't want to
interrupt those and we don't do that
here as well so here we have those v2
clusters we had set up exactly how we
expected it to but we still have those
v1 clusters that players are still
playing on available and still up and
running so we don't interrupt player
experience in the slightest
awesome well we're really excited about
Google cloud game servers and we're
really excited about working with
customers and developers who are wanting
to work on this platform
most recently jam CD just pushed out
their production workload on top of a
Ghana's world war doe which is an
amazing game that you should totally
check out we're really excited to be
working with them on their project I'm
really great to have them having a
production workload running on a gun as
right now so if you want to get started
with Google cloud game servers you can
do serve right now it is in public beta
and available to everyone there is a two
phase
that is happening here so phase one
which is available right now as I just
said is GCP only and provides basic
policy management capabilities this
means that you can run your applications
and your games on gke and you have basic
functionality that we'll deal with most
of your workloads for auto-scaling and
how you want to manage your fleets phase
2 which will come in the near future and
we're actively working on will provide
more sophisticated and advanced policy
management in terms of allocation or
time based scaling but also will provide
multi and hybrid cloud support which
we're also really excited about as well
because as we've been talking about
sometimes you just need to be able to
get these game servers to players in the
places that they are and that having
that flexibility is hugely hugely
powerful so we're really excited about
both these developments and we really
want you to get involved keep an ear out
for all the next phase developments as
well we're definitely going to be
looking for people to test out those
alpha features that we roll out in the
future so if you want to get started
there's a QuickStart available on the
screen right now please take the step by
step process because then you'll be able
to get something up and running on your
cluster and being able to play a game
finally thank you so much for spending
your time with me and learning today
about Google cloud game servers we're
really excited about working with you
and your games and we really want to see
what you're gonna build next thank you
so much
[Music]